Прагматична і консервативна.
У німецьких ЗМІ її називають "міні-Меркель" з іменем,
яке важко вимовити: Аннеґрет Крамп-Карренбауер.
- Я знаю: в мене складне ім'я і ніхто
не може вимовити Крамп-Карренбауер по літерах.
Але не все так складно, якщо говорити Акака.
Ще донедавна АКК, Аннеґрет Крамп-Карренбауер,
була в Берліні, та й загалом у Німеччині, маловідомою особою.
При цьому мати трьох дітей - дуже досвідчена
та успішна регіональна політикиня. У минулому
вона керувала найменшою федеральною землею Німеччини -
Зааром, на кордоні з Францією та Люксембургом.
Ще у 18 років Крамп-Карренбауер вступила до партії
ХДС - Християнсько-демократичний союз.
Вона - віруюча католичка та виступає
за християнські цінності. За своїми політичними
поглядами Аннеґрет Крамп-Карренбауер найближча з усіх до Анґели Меркель.
Так, щодо Росії вона, приміром,
прихильниця дипломатії. Щоправда,
у нещодавньому інтерв'ю німецькому телеканалу АRD
вона повідомила, що готова розглянути й жорсткіші дії
щодо Кремля, якщо він продовжуватиме агресію у Керченській протоці.
- Як ми можемо дати зрозуміти, що Азовське море
має залишатися відкритим для, скажімо,
міжнародного судноплавства. Одна з можливостей
була б: доти, доки ескалація триває, домовитися з
європейськими й американськими портами
не пускати туди російські кораблі з тих регіонів.
На тлі ескалації навколо Азовського моря
Аннеґрет Крамп-Карренбауер критично
висловлюється і щодо будівництва "Північного потоку-2".
Зупинити проект - складний процес, але:
- Але  можна вплинути на те, скільки газу буде постачати цей газопровід!
Крамп-Карренбауер критично ставиться
до одностатевих шлюбів, виступає за жорсткіші
правила абортів та міграційних норм, зокрема щодо
покарання мігрантів, які вводять владу в оману щодо країни свого походження.
Протягом виборчої кампанії експерти говорили, що
в разі перемоги АKK у Меркель найбільше шансів
залишитися на посаді канцлерки до кінця терміну,
який спливає в 2021 році.